allez on va accueillir dans la game boy
alors moi jeis vous dire j'ai déjà
reconnu j'ai même pas besoin de poser
des questions tellement je le connais
bien tellement je suis fan tellement je
l'adore je sais déjà qui c'est moi les
gars on peut déjà c'est rideau alle-y
poser les questions qui est la surprise
Poulin qui
vienterim le Poulin le Poulin qui vient
se
manger non c'est pas on aura aimé mais
c'est pas Jean Le Poulin parisque Jean
Le Poulin viendra dans la
spéciale fa une spéciale avec que des
personnes qui nous ont quitté euh les
Chéries euh
un animateur télé je l'adore il le sait
qui jette son micro il jette son micro
ah ça
voilà il est
tropon estvec
9 a
nous cont de
voir on adore cette
émission Philipp tu sais que je te kiffe
tellement je te jure ah c'est toi mais
oui c'est moi d'accord le micro tu l'as
tu l'as bien tu comment tu leuras
de micro à la production parce que tu as
dû en faire tomber des fois non très peu
non non mais là j'ai fait une émission
en Belgique récemment évidemment je l'ai
là je l'ai vraiment planté là ouais tu
l'as planté alors Philippe on voulait
revenir sur les jeux avec toi tu es la
plus grande star des jeux des années 90
il pas voilà je vais vous dire c'est
c'est c'est le number one et je suis
très content que tu sois là avec nous on
va revenir d'abord bien entendu on
pouvait pas on est obligé à chaque fois
que tu viens je la repasse c'est que
c'est ma première télé c'était avec toi
et c'était dans le juste prix avec mon
ami gabise regardez sa cravate et vous
comprenez un petit peu le le gars
regardez venez venez les deux làene
venezene je vais vous montrer venez
venez tous les deux oui tous les deux
venez venez venez al vous allez me faire
la même ambiance on va faire petit
interview de Carlos vous me faites la
même ambiance que celle que vous mettez
dans le public actuellement Carlos
bonjourour pH vous venez d'où Carlos
j'avais ver les
temps et vous avez gagné quoi cette
semaine Carlos j'ai gagné un
camescope et un équipement des quitation
d'accord physiquement on a quasiment pas
changé c'est vra c'est vrai c'est toi tu
as pas changé vraiment tu es le même par
contre Gabis a changé je pas si tu l'as
vu mais une cadar voilà les gens on va
revoir bien sûr une compile de jeux dans
les années 90 tu as vu que le juste prix
allait revenir sur M6 j'ai vu ça ouis
c'est bien c'est bien bien ouais c'est
une marque forte oui ça ça sa place sur
et puis er Antoine j'adore ouais j'aime
bien animateur en plus je pense qu'ils
ont fait les bons choix après je pense
ça va marcher et moi le juste prix
j'adore c'est un de mes jeux préférés
sais que je suis passé au pupitre moi
après ah oui mais je me suis énervé acun
une meuf te rappellees pas j'étais je
t'explique je passe au pupitre c'était
pas une meuf qui s'appelait Marion qui
faisait le casting si oui et ouais je
m'en rappelle et elle m'avait choisi au
casting après je suis venu et j'avais
une meuf à côté dès que je disais 900 €
elle disait 901
€ bah c'est le jeu je suis reparti avec
un livre un livre des records céit ça le
jeu principe non mais tu sais je me suis
vén après je dis vas-y toi vas-y fais ta
vie arrête de te copier sur moi c dis
vas-y elle viens elle copie tout sur moi
cette meuf là c'est un truc de ouf d je
disais je disais 15501 j'ai copie sur
quelqu'un d'autre qu'est-ce qui t'arrive
toi je te jure je me rappelle une meuf à
côté de moi je me suis embrouillé avec
elle elle a été sélectionné en plus
grâce à moi elle est partie avec un four
à micron on détour je te jure je suis
curé on va regarder compile des jeux des
années 90
[Musique]
regardez vous avez le choix entre de
boule je conviendrai plus hein c'est
sympa millionnaire franchement
franchement
[Rires]
oui et vous êtes passé à la peinture
tuas les mains
propres c'est pas des Chen non
mais sur la peinture il faut pas du
grases je vous offre un cadeau c'est
très gentil avant de je vous en prie
ouvrez-le je vais tenir le micro
allez-y faites voir aux gens
hein j'espère que c'est votre taille
attendez tenez ça tenez ça moi je vais
vous l'essayer j'espère votre paquet qui
va rentrer
dedans regardez pas mon derrière pour
rigoler de moi
[Musique]
derrièreon je change que pas ma
parti
le millionnaire le millionnaire c'est
incroyable incroyable et tr télétat tu
kiffais parce que ça c'était que de
l'animation où tu vis ah c'est de
l'improvisation enfin je lisais un petit
peu quand même le curriculum vit ce qui
ven ou mais une fois que j'avais vu que
la moitié met le PSG que l'autre moitié
mais
Marseille je te j qu'est-ce que je
kiffais et je rêvais moi d'avoir les TR
tél c'est vrai ouais moi j'avais fait un
j'avais fait des faux TR tél oui je je
sais excusemoi tu es
con je t'adore c'est vra je t'aurais
bien eu en candidat en
fait franchement le million frère moi je
le problème que tu as c'est quand tu vas
là-bas il y avait un problème l'émission
la kiffe c'est que tu te dis toute la
semaine tu es avec tes potes tout ça tu
dis frère je vais taper le million c'est
sûr tuar je voyais toute la la tête des
gars qui partient avec
100000ur par que c'est vrai oua parce
qu'en plus c'est pas toute la semaine
c'est grosso modo 3 mois avant on avait
tellement on avait tellement de gagnants
qu'on enchaînaitouis c'est vrai
peu prs ou partis avec 100000 Ch volis
les gars ils faisaient la gueule ah il
cétait du en plus des fois ça faisait
tout le monde crit le million le million
la boule elle faisait le million après
oh elle était juste à côté elle
repartait comme ça elle repartait 100000
mais c'est 100000 c'est génial ouais je
suis venu pour prendre le million qui
cass les couilles je te jure c'est un
truc de fou PhIP j'adorais j'adorais et
le juste prix bien entendu on a fait une
petite compile du Juste Prix on rappelle
que tu as sorti ta ta mémoire tes
mémoires he tu étais venu nous voir ici
euh dites bien à mon fils que je l'aime
dans ton livre il y a des tu fais des
des grosses confessions et vraiment je
te dis n on t'adore on adore quand tu
viens nous voir ben ça me fait plaisir
tu sais que le public te kiffe de fou
encore mais je te jure à chaque fois que
tu viens les gens sont comme des oufs et
ben ça ça me touche énormément ouis ça
fait plaisir parce que ça c'était a
c'est il y a 20 ans quand même hein
c'était pas hier matin oua mais je sais
mais regarde on va voir d'autres images
du Juste Prix regarde c'est parti vous
allez maintenant pouvoir jouer au juste
prix qui vous est présenté par Philippe
Risoli qu'est-ce qui ne coûte pas
[Musique]
Frans votre femme est là elle se
prénomme votre
femme il faut pas avir forcément
d'allusion coquine dans mes propos je
vais vous le prouver tout de suite parce
que on vous m
doigts comme ça ben c'était pas bon
voici maintenant cy Rapa qui arrive de
Bordeaux
vous êtes prêts ouais j'ai
gagné si vous nous rejoignez il est
22h49 on est en direct dansen Touche pas
à mon poste les années 90 Philippe
risolier est avec nous pour revenir on
est revenu sur le juste prix sur le
millionnaire qui a déjà gagné un petit
peu un petit un petit truc au
millionnaire ouis rien je je le faisais
tout le temps je rêvais de venir te voir
je te jure quand je t'ai vu tu sais que
là c'était la première fois que je
pouvais faire de la télé en plus ouais
ouais je donc dès que j'étais majeur
j'ai dit je vais aller faire le juste
prix je suis rentré chez moi j'ai dit à
ma mère c'est bon ça y est ma carrière
est lancée j'ai vu rizoli il m'a kiffé
et tout je te jure que c'est vrai j'ai
dit à ma mère ça y est c'est fait c'est
fini c'est fini oublie-moi je parle même
pas avec moi parle pas avec moi parle
pas avec moi qui s parler là je te jure
que c'est vrai vas-y Risoli m'a repéré
là ça y est m'a fait venir et tout je
raconé percé je dis ça y est j'ai percé
moi oubliez-moi là ça y est là elle m'a
dit vas-y va mettre la table qu'est-ce
je la
table j'ai V Roli il m'a repéré j'ai dit
tu es ouf ou quoi c'est vraiment
véridique demande à ma mère je suis
arrivé avec un livre de record m'a dit
tuas repéré t'as donné un livre de
record va dans ta chambre espèce de que
tu es je te jure que c'est vrai ouais tu
sais que j'éta j'étais sûr que j'allais
j'allais j'allais décoller là je voulais
faire de la télé là déjà bah tu as quand
même décollé finalement ah oui P ptait
long la piste était longue rester
longtemps sur la piste